première chose l'abattement fiscal ne
disparaît pas son plafond est modifié il
est réduit de moitié il passe donc de
5100 euros pour les antilles à environ
2300 euros pour mieux comprendre une
personne seule qui a un salaire situé
entre 1300 et 1600 euros avec
l'abattement de 30% sept personnes ne
paient pas d'impôts avec la réforme
elle devrait payer au minimum 200 euros
par an un couple sans enfant ayant
revenus avoisinant les 5000 euros
mensuels qui paient à peu près 8500
euros d'impôts par an paiera avec la
réforme de 1500 euros de plus chaque
année soit onze mille euros en revanche
pour les très bas salaires
ceux qui ne sont pas imposables qui
gagnent environ moins de 1000 euros net
par mois rien ne change il reste non
imposables contrairement à ce qui a été
annoncé par le gouvernement cette
réforme selon l'ordre des experts
comptables va toucher l'ensemble des
contribuables
il faut savoir que seulement 30% des
foyers martiniquais sont imposables
c'est que touche le smic qui ne sont pas
imposés aujourd'hui avec la diminution
et les risques de rentrée bien entendu
dans la zone importante
on n'est entrepris une nouvelle tranche
de vous avouera mais on est en train de
créer une nouvelle population d'apolda
toujours pour les experts comptables
cette réforme de l'abattement de 30%
aurait également un impact négatif sur
l'économie martiniquaise plus on a de
l'argent plus on participe à l'activité
économique
on dépense ont fait circuler la théorie
et sa trésorerie qui ce qui ne permet
bien entendu de relancer l'économie
si donc dans une
dans un département qui est déjà victime
au chômage ont réduit encore le pouvoir
d'achat de la population
on estime quand même que c'est ça ne
peut être malheureux et donc nous
experts-comptables aux enfants il faudra
sûrement attendre une levée de boucliers
face à cette mesure mais cela aura t'il
réellement un effet 86